one beat on the inside of the arm one
beat on the outside of the arm switching
makes a two
beat isolation on the inside of the arm
isolation on the outside of the arm
switching makes a two beat
[Music]
isolation stretch the hand path left to
right along the x- AIS PO is rotating
around the x-axis the hand is rotating
around the XA
for the poison wheel
P stretch and stretch and
stretch eventually it comes a
stall you can even reverse
Direction One Beat above the
arm one beat below the
arm switching makes a two
be isolation above the
arm isolation below the
arm switching makes a 2B isolation and
floor plane
[Music]
One Beat in front one beat in back is a
two be
isolation in front isolation in
back 2v
isolation stretch the hand front and
back along the C
axis toy is rotating and Wall playing
around the C axis the hand is rotating
around the cais
[Music]
w
didn't me
you but I guess you got to
sto me away from
your me
[Music]
down didn't mean to
you but I guess you
got St away from
your down
[Music]
didn't mean to tell
you but I guess you got
[Music]